hello everyone oh good snacks and I
wasn't putting snacks down using stags
okay welcome to they need to know
everybody this is a weekly deep dive
into all the biggest stories you need to
know about now as we look forward look
ahead to 2018 we thought we would spend
this episode discussing a subject we all
need to know about the future of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe which
characters will get their own solo films
how will the Avengers evolve or
disappear what new comic book storylines
should be adapted and will deadpool and
spiderman never kiss you know dead
miners spiderman to mind we'll talk
about all this stuff but first I am your
host Eric Weiss and the rest of these
beautiful gurus are Sam all right well
let's start with our top story everybody
Marvel phase four currently we are in
the middle of Phase three of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe which began with
Captain America Civil War in 2016 and
we'll end with the second of two
upcoming Avengers movies in 2019
beautiful graphic right very helpful now
a Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige has
been reluctant to give details about
phase four saying that it would add
imput won't come out for a while and
that he's focused on the remaining phase
3 movies black panther Avengers spinet
infinity war ant-man in the wasp Captain
Marvel in the fourth Avengers movie
maybe Feige has a dent to give the
titles of these MCU movies beyond 2019
because he doesn't want to spoil which
characters will survive these big
Avengers showdowns possibly that was
something that he got heat for in Phase
two
we all went at age of Ultron knowing
that none of the main characters were in
real dangerous movies after that it's
also possible that bug is holding off
because these rumored negotiations
between Marvel and Fox are still
secretly happening baby
now that deal whatever does go through
it would be a huge huge game-changer
Marvel Studios would regain the rights
over all the x-men Deadpool and cable
and Fantastic Four and Doctor Doom it's
conceivable that Marvel would have to
reboot or could reboot all these major
events
like Civil War anyway let's quickly
update ourselves on what we do know
about Bayes for the limited details we
do now cool okay Mikey said to the
fourth Avengers movie scheduled for may
2019 will mark the end of phase three in
the beginning of phase four that'll be
kind of the turning point and there are
three predictions we can make here okay
the I know I'm talking a lot very
possible and we'll see the deaths the
deaths deaths of major the main Avengers
in the upcoming movies Iron Man Captain
America Thor ha have all at this point
completed their own trilogies right and
four and all four Avengers movie add
four of interest of that sorry that's
seven movies for each of them not
counting their cameos and other movies
like spider-man homecoming that's a lot
of Gen 1 Avengers and 18 months now you
can imagine yeah they got a day off and
they might want to move on with another
generation to go
yeah which which do you guys think are
the most ready to go or is it time to
say goodbye to move on from Chris Evans
seems done yeah not that he's not done a
good job at all back in the freezer
please go to sleep I don't want to work
anymore
he'll probably be gone you can do a fun
thing with either Falcon or Bucky taking
over for cap if you really wanted a cap
yeah but like he's not like a spider-man
he's really good but he's not like a
spider-man so you don't necessarily need
a Captain America to keep going forward
you could probably Robert Downey jr. or
he'll be like exactly what him anymore
no uh he comes too much he gets billing
before the title of the movie comes up
it's insane
I probably Thor because they want
success of Ragnarok yeah
they set up balcony they set up get Korg
a movie man losing out on Vice doing
like screw around his Thor he did
Dancing with the Stars he knows what
he's doing
yeah he did that pre anything else in
his career I don't think there's any way
I mean I'll probably
it's gonna be like a loop like there's
no way they kill her over Thor's like
death now he ain't dead he's gonna just
like get just popped right in the
beginning of the first movie I think in
age of Ultron when stark had that vision
which we're kind of looking at here I
think that was kind of like our first
promise to from Feige of like hey these
people can die and it's not so bad this
isn't so traumatic right we kind of want
to see some of these corpses right
Quicksilver without thinking about it
twice right
we killed a couple more maybe he's just
sad about over a little bit if we lose
Clint is his first name if we lose him I
swear - I can't Island he's most
important to me in these movies I can't
he does he's got a farm he's gotta chop
the wood on the policy lines like you
need to go stop Ultron face we need more
of her trying to like choke those words
I'm sending my husband off to fight a
robot yeah Kang the Conqueror you got a
shoot an arrow out of me equivalent of
throwing rocks there's some rocks of the
bad guys oh I think also Nick Fury is
gonna be dead basically dead bring
Coulson back findings like no 82 shields
happening
BAM another pop just like pop pop Thor
Coulson down you're like well and also
Samuel Jackson's like days away from
Paris at 40 oh so young so youthful oh
god no he's a natural causes may take
Nick yeah well there are a few phase 4
movies that are safe beds even though
they haven't been officially announced
yet by the studio like we'll probably
get two more spider-man movies at least
and Marvel is continuing its partnership
with Sony I would imagine there Tom
Holland did let that slip in an
interview that it would be a trillion
he's like oh god I'm a kid I say too
much they gotta stop
they're also almost certainly will be a
third guardians of the galaxy it's have
a no brainer at this point and a second
Doctor Strange director that movie scott
derrickson did hint that he wanted to
set up nightmare to be a villain in any
second movie that got made nights him
there would be that's kind of a question
right like it's Thor got three and two
of those are kind of duds so
Benedict Cumberbatch I don't know like
after his profile with Sherlock and all
that I don't know if he would want to be
contractually tied in but if he's
actually tidy and it's already happened
and in novel lines his sole right and it
like sorcerer supreme is the title that
can be passed down to someone else so if
he can't do it you can imagine them
bringing in someone else I'm not
expected to live in strange I mean yeah
I mean strange easily storytelling wise
has plenty of room for multiple movies i
yeah i think benedict cumberbatch once
there they show him how many zeroes he's
got on that contract he's not gonna say
no like throw money at especially yeah
and I think guardians all those actors
are probably gonna be on board for as
many as they can to work with Tim Gunn
that just seems like they're having a
blast on those movies nervous
okay is the mentor isn't he on your
chairs can I get out of beautiful
fabrics gun is the I consulted on
everything they're wearing I don't have
a Tim Gunn cameo and he'll be one of the
other elders of the universe and then
for sure yeah I mean it'd be super fun
to see more spider-man I mean we talked
about what would the names be right so
we had homecoming is there gonna be a
spider-man graduation a spider-man we
can definitely look forward to those but
there are other MCU properties that
could get more movies but it's gonna
depend on how successful their upcoming
phase 3 movies are I think we can assume
Black Panther will be a huge hit in
February yeah I think Marvel's gonna
want to give him sequels in phase 4 same
goes maybe for ant-man in the wasp we'll
see how that one does but forgotten
Marvel it seems like another characters
being positioned to take over the
franchise but who do you guys think who
do you want to be the new Tony Stark of
the oh yeah it's coming out
I literally bug spray it goes Avengers
3rd Deadpool next month following month
ant-man and wasp it's this is July
release its its I totally forgot about
everyone even the back monitor forgot
about it you could end up being a
surprise hit I don't know I I'm super
excited to see T'Challa and a black pant
I would love for him to be the news if
he was that'd be insane and I'm not like
any good it would be amazing and but he
just need it's the reason why the Tony
Stark Robert engine works because it's
Robert Downey jr. give me give us
somebody that can just like it has this
huge presence when he comes on even
doing small roles even spider-man it's
just like yeah this just feels right
this is the world were in it makes sense
so if the father of it all yeah that
authority and that presence and yeah
instance he's a king let's see him bring
that like presence give him like you
know help whatever
thank you that plenty of time [ __ ] man
he's still alive after everything's gone
down well speaking of already J and
let's actually or no that's not to be
you've already just a later topic all
right as I mentioned before or many
DubLi the possibility of merging movie
universes are still in the works the
create a few interesting paradoxes of
those Marvel Fox world's ever combined
for example we've Josh Brolin plays a
Thanos in the MCU but he also plays
Cable in the upcoming Deadpool 2 we are
a trivia question here I want to ask you
guys let's not forget the Fox and Marvel
with our friend Chris Evans well
actually so that is one of the answers
that you could write down here besides
Josh Brolin what other actors have
crossed over between comics superhero
cinematic universes it's his name as
many as you came to 36 we won't start
the 30 seconds yeah but Chris Evans yeah
is another one so besides Josh Brolin
and Chris Evans write down as many as
you can 30 seconds starting 3 2 1 now go
for it you can make an argument for it
I just have a mind blank my students as
a time pressure on something I've got no
idea what to do and the best thing about
this is that while I eat I'm actually
talking during a 30 second blank really
where I don't even know and that is time
okay so and put your name on it and and
we'll put it down there and we'll get to
the I want to put one more go ahead okay
the person who names the most obviously
will win the most accurate ones okay so
yeah the person who names most will win
will get the honors of saying goodbye as
modest just ready and we'll get to the
person who wins will get to say our
names our Twitter handle so ever they
want and pick on the loser who names the
fewest or things that are not names I'm
a right you read my answer it's gonna
make you guys bad they're gonna suffer
some horrible fate that we'll get to
later yeah okay while we're on the
subject emergency burger world's one
popular Marvel comic series that has yet
to be adapted to screen which has a lot
of fans hoping to see it some version of
and phase four is Secret Wars that is a
crossover series in which a cosmic
entity known as the Beyonder teleports a
number of Marvel heroes to battle world
to fight against their will using a
bunch of alien weaponry and technology
it features the Avengers the x-men
spider-man Fantastic Four bunch of all
the Marvel characters including villains
like Ultron Doctor Doom [ __ ] and a later
Deadpool comic actually retcon to him
into the Secret Wars as well the wasp
caused all the other characters to
forget he was part of it
so I thought it'd be fun to use this for
a pitch meet segment guys let's assume
Secret Wars could be adapted into a
Marvel phase for a movie let's also
assume that these Fox Marvel deals go
through and that the x-men Deadpool and
Fantastic Four could be part of it as
well I want you guys to pitch me what
crossover battleworld matchup would you
like to see in the sequel wars movies
superheroes mates Hunger Games basically
yeah
cool thank you for having you're not
supposed to be here I want to thank you
for having me back in the pitch room I
know we haven't used any of my ideas yet
I'm not taking that personally I know
some of the projects are in development
let me tell you about my favorite part
of Secret Wars and what I want to see I
want to see the fight between the thing
and Johnny Storm when when when they
when cuz after the course ends Johnny
Storm returns to Earth with the things
girlfriend who they are have since
broken up and they get married but she's
actually a squirrel in disguise so I
want them to hash out being married to
the same person or being in a
relationship the same woman and also
during Secret Wars Colossus and Kitty
Pryde break up so I would just see like
a Bobby Drake Ice Man Kitty Pryde
Colossus you know kind of like battle
for the love of Kitty Pryde I'm all
about the relationships here some kids
love romance okay I think more young
adult romance in these things you know
we need to space between us we need
whatever that shawshank redemption' know
what was the one where they mentioned
the space baton or stars in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you know what because
we all have thoughts and we all love
stars anyway thanks for letting me pitch
glad mine was the worst again you were
the first to go already though I would
like to see matchups where it's like - I
see what I would like to go this game
way back to dad Justice League but
seeing Superman and the flash have a
race like that for me is exciting using
things that are not just fighting but
like other skills in that is a powerful
skill why people don't have it too
similar powers going head to head said
the all the flying yes human superhumans
go together
and they'll have like a flying match
with the lawyers the Matt Murdock could
litigate each other how do we get out of
here bring the Johnnie Cochran classic
matchup Hulk vs. Wolverine I think let's
name our favorite superhero movie on
three one two three Fantastic Four
original daredevil Elektra best part of
that movie is when Johnny Storm for some
reason can absorb everyone else's powers
what I'm thinking is Peter Parker gets
everybody's powers he's getting Hulk's
power he's getting Wolverines powers
he's getting an Iron Man suit
he's got Cyclops his eyes things he's
got the thing rocks Colossus also metal
he can turn on the flames he can
teleport like Nightcrawler he's got
wings like Wall Street can shrink how he
touches something he literally that's
what the super Silver Surfer and he to
because of the space cloud God and then
he can he could get all the other powers
on the planet and the planet was
actually was it Galactica the plan seek
rewards is just battleworld like ego
versus glass that happens all the time
it's awesome but don't do big space
cloud do giant man with fork for a head
and he's just like a meatball I want to
see venom vs. Hulk just because I would
love to see some kind of version that
battle where you have like the Brawn
version but also the mental battle of
like banner versus Eddie Brock like in
the mind
yeah they switch back yeah it was like a
tag-team match as we learned from Thor 3
Ragnarok the Hulk's of the wheel and
banners in the trunk of the car ok
co-pilots anymore I would really like
they did a sequel to Secret Wars called
Secret Wars great time again they did it
again
but it was really cool because they what
happened was the multiverse exploded and
they took chunks of it and they try to
made up make up planted out of it and it
doesn't like survive it can't last for a
long time but you had different
universes all around so that would be a
cool way to have the weird Sony like
properties like venom and everything
like that that's one thing then you have
your MCU then you have your x-men maybe
both versions bring back the old
versions again for some raising a
Patrick Stewart and Hugh Jackman there
you have Deadpool over here you could
have who's left Fantastic Four figure
that out just figure that out as fast as
you can and then at the end it all
merges together into one big goop one
big planet I can do one thing what goop
you would like to see in the comments
down below yeah yeah but let's move on
to our next topic which I'll lead you
guys into by the numbers I have two
numbers that for you guys I found
interesting 409 million in two hundred
forty two million okay those are not
just random just numbers that look
aesthetically pleasing me those are the
amounts of money made per Marvel movie
on average with Robert Downey jr. and
without Robert Downey jr. right okay so
in other words these 7 MCU movies with
Tony Stark in them have made an average
of 409 million each in the 10 without
him have made an average of 242 million
each now these are domestic box office
numbers by the way not global but
they're pretty much reflected in the
it's or even amplified when you start
going internationally it's no question
that our DJ is Marvel's biggest star
it's why he's consistently one of the
top paid actors in the world currently
to be fair his movies have tended to be
the bigger tentpole events of the MCU
like the Avengers movies civil war
spider-man homecoming meanwhile the
guardians movies in Thor Ragnarok have
proven that can there can still be
successful in scene movies without him
for sure but if Marvel plans on parting
ways with Robert Downey jr. at any point
in the future at the end of phase 3
maybe the plan and plan to pursue a
phase 4 without him will they lose
as a result of that is there anyone else
name see who can rake it in like our DJ
that's real tough they're really trying
in the comments right in the comics
right now with our Erie Williams it's a
hard name for me to say yeah female Iron
Man but it's Iron Heart and they're
really trying to push that hard you had
died yet Don Cheadle and then they I
don't know if they still want to use him
- he's not like working really well but
that's also a name and a presence that
could work they just have totally
butchered his character and it's a big
bummer but he could have been someone
that would have like take up the mantle
and done a good job not my warmest yeah
I don't I think if they're if they want
star power they're the you know merging
with Fox might be that might be part of
the reason why that's happening is
because there is potential news star
power that they could do that with
Jennifer Lawrence Tom Cruise always
sells like he always does anybody would
just like be weird I mean but I mean
like I get why they did it and also I'll
go see every Mission Impossible I saw
edge of tomorrow because of him and that
was a really good decision because that
movie was amazing it was a really good
movie oh well usually he sells really
well even though he's like I'm feeling
good about you know I mentioned Black
Panther to Charla I think that will be a
big hit I hope it becomes a crossover
hit because like he does seem he has
like kind of the the stark angle of like
having a suit that is manufactured with
all kinds of different elements to it
but he also has this like rich backstory
and mythology to him that I would love
to see that be kind of the face of
Marvel now that's just mean Steve Carell
yeah as anything Mole Man be a mole man
yeah man um it's all I got guys yeah I
don't feel like there's a window open
for Robert Downey jr. to make a good
chunk of money into is like late sixties
pop it into these things like as a like
mentor kind of like basically extended
cameo hang in these where it's like he
shoots two weeks and that's all instead
of six months the new Stanley kind of
say
oh yeah that's not a bad idea yeah
Bryan Cranston also could pull off like
nah I don't know I don't think he has
the same star power but he could have
the same presence we've been amazing
even now because lex luthor's his age is
all over never too late yeah and you
could be aged as much as you like and
see let's move on to another possibility
of Marvel phase four that I'm really
look forward to talking about we'll face
for finally see the rise of women in the
MCU right many believe that the success
of Wonder Woman over Wonder Woman over
in the DC EU is made it possible for a
Hollywood studio executives to give more
female characters a chance to star in
their own solo films now of course
before we start getting mad at me Marvel
has already had Captain Marvel in the
works for a while now wasp is now
sharing top billing with ant-man there
are a ton of other powerful ladies that
have already appeared in great roles in
it on-screen MCU Black Widow Scarlet
Witch Valkyrie never got in their own
movies but hopefully that may happen now
some have proposed an adaptation of Lady
liberators which in which Valkyrie in
the comics leads an all-female team of
Marvel heroes including Black Widow wasp
Scarlet Witch and Medusa so movie bummer
that Medusa's just got ruined on that TV
show yes a big old bummer yeah from the
Inhumans yeah there are others who are
pushing for a she-hulk movie which would
have the bonus of allowing Marvel to put
Hulk in future movies considering a
different studio still into rights to
any solo Hulk movies and she holds an
amazing characters like retains her like
sense of humor and her wit that I would
love to see in a movie anyway do you
guys think that Marvel should go in any
of these directions any particular these
directions yes there should have been a
Black Widow no bruh five years ago and
now it feels like if they do a black
widow movie they're tacking it on in an
attempt to kind of like placate fans
like being like sure that's the same way
they didn't do enough toys I mean there
should be I would like to see a black
widow movie anyway but like where why
hasn't that happened yet yeah why was
she always left out of the six pack and
they put the bad guy in did the Ultron
is the perfect example where it was like
all of the Avengers in Ultron except for
Black Widow and Scarlett Johansson has
proven she is one of the like eight or
nine people in the world who can
truly open a big Hollywood movie like
she can do it like give her Lucy I I'm
very interested to see how Captain
Marvel goes especially because brie
Larson sounds very dedicated to
involving herself in the superhero arena
the fact that she wants to direct her
movie I think that's a great step in a
good direction because I think Wonder
Woman couldn't have been one a woman
without a patty Jenkins and when I hear
things like Taika Waititi saying I would
love to direct a standalone Black Widow
movie I'm like yes but mmm like you'd be
amazing I just think you need a female
to direct a female hero mm-hmm because
we've seen the difference that it makes
just look at Wonder Woman in her
standalone movie and look at Wonder
Woman in Justice League and it's they
can they can roll the dice they can take
a chance on maybe an unproven director
they did that in Phase one of the Marvel
movies like they you know not all these
directors had produced Joss Whedon
hadn't directed a full huge superhero
franchise movie before and he made it
something great out of it he was like
the best thing that happened to them so
like there's plenty of great female
directors out there well not plenty
unfortunately but there are enough that
they can hopefully use to open the gate
to even more female directors now it'd
be really cool you need more and I think
team-up movies are a good way to like
sell and get people in the seats also as
a way to like to introduce people in the
new characters you could have an
all-female team like Lady Liberty's is
one that's cool I know there was like
some rumors that Tessa Thompson tweeted
out that did you mention that like they
pitched a movie already like of a female
team they already write that is Robbie
who wants to take Harley Quinn with ya
which would sell billions that would do
very very well but no like it would be
amazing like you have a lot of really
cool characters I think America Chavez
who's really big and Marvel right now
she's the paramedic of the multiverse
which is an amazing title that could be
a lot of fun and like girls could look
up to her I mean I if she's one of my
favorite characters to read right now I
don't know there's there's a lot of fun
they could have in phase four and I
think team-ups would be really
interesting and just picking the
characters that you haven't gotten the
spotlight like I mean they could have
done basically atomic blonde like that
kind of spy type story because she I
don't really remember the movie but I
think she was a Soviet spy as well and
like I you guys and correct me if I'm
wrong but like a but like that's the
thing you could you could have done that
with the red
and everything like that it had been
really interesting but no yeah you're
right they missed the they totally
missed the boat on it now it feels like
it's a missing piece movie like there's
been other movies that we didn't maybe
need very successfully by building up
the solar storylines and providing rich
experiences in solo movies and then
bringing the team together and it's like
everyone had this except her really well
they had team ups as well like the Hulk
tried and denied but that was like that
was the only piece missing and it could
have been done then and now I think
freaking Hollywood's gonna say how old
is Scarlett Johansson now I think the
Marvel brand is strong enough to sustain
any kind of risk you know just speaking
to the studio executives who were just
looking at this is a bottom line like
there's you have this strong brand you
can afford to take a chance to because
you know we saw a DC do it with Wonder
Woman which that should not have been a
chance that was taken that should have
been like an obvious no brainer sure bet
and that should have been done decades
ago but the fact that like now it's
finally happening let's just like jump
on board I mean we're probably preaching
the choir I don't know I always feel
weird telling like no we want no
female-driven movie right ya know male
robot but she-hulk though I mean
everyone has pitched this before but
like as a Netflix series she would line
up really well with like Luke Cage and
Daredevil and Jessica Jones it would be
really cool mmm be really cool and but
it's a bummer because of like that
Marvel is not really looking at the TV
side of it one of my favorite runs of
the Avengers it's Luke Cage leading them
and it's really cool jessica jones as a
part of it spider-man's a part of it
Hawkeye is Ronan as a part of it who
doesn't use a bow he like fights hand to
hand it's really cool you have Iron Man
cap you have a bunch oh yeah Bucky cap
you have no you're Bucky's Captain
America in there it's really cool but it
sucks because I want my culture to be in
the movie and I don't know if they'd
ever do that
transitions although I think
this could be I might just be lying I
feel like the Netflix Marvel actors are
signed to like they can't refuse to be
in the movies I was up with their
contract you know like there's like some
sort of thing where like if they are
like we're gonna call on you guys cuz
Netflix is like prestigious to like
cameo like they can't say like no I'm
only on the TV show like their contracts
include options to appear in the movie
that where it's the same consistent
characters in both film and TV or what
DC is doing where they have separate
runs of CW TV shows and then completely
different characters playing the movie
version if they oh if they didn't say
that this was a part of the whole same
thing then I wouldn't care if there were
different actors but since they said
this is all of the same universe a
reference the events that happen the
timeline is the same time so cinematic
in their own way like they're basically
movies that are 13 hours long oh my god
he can't talk and he's wearing a
full-face mask the entire time let us
move on now to or Nev no lightning round
each other with some rapid fire off the
questions and you guys tweeted us these
questions thank you so much we have to
answer them in a limited timely fashion
I have to ask some hopefully atomic
fashion and make sure to tweet us for
our next video what will tweet out and
respond with the questions you want us
to answer here we go okay um mod what
obscure 90s reference would you want on
a shirt that's from a try infer okay
I've got the one that Joey was like how
you doing no no not from friends Oh Joey
Lawrence
[Laughter]
okay here we go
what Sam what song from at Danny Boy
what song would you like to listen to
for the rest of your life one song one
one song we get to listen to the rest
really the Ghostbusters walk the moon
remix not the Fall Out Boy remix and I
have to lightning Tommy and Amelia JK
tweets what is love and someone already
was respond to that baby don't hurt me
as a way to keep us monogamous in
relationships it's false it's not real
love
listen I sit in my wedding dress by a
fireplace every night as I raised my
young daughter a teacher to never love
and it works for us as a family if you
don't mind I'd like to just talk for a
few more
yeah you know around this young stable
boy recently who has leather boots and
calls jacks names and we just don't
approve of him to be the princess bride
synopsis no I think you're having
not-so-great expectations about what I'm
talking about
wasn't it my friend okay for myself at
Edwin M Lillibridge says what movie or
serie or TV series characters do you
identify with the most probably all the
minions
weird and I thought my answer was
scarred I just imagined you made up of a
bunch of those little things I have a
little like a minute black you know
there's I was just kidding you should
all aim the minion for Tim Gunn not me
okay - I believe ya thank you by the way
you guys for for tweeting all these and
we very much appreciate it
let's move on to our 15-second shout out
where each of us gets 15 seconds to shut
up plug a ram about anything we want Sam
why don't you begin moms brought this up
before but I'm going to call it Super
Mario Odyssey I beat it really fast and
I've been replaying it over and over
again it's a means and
I just re-watched
the last Jedi and it's to just say watch
it again three times let's watch
together
shout out to holiday music how let me
tell you my top three of all time Lambs
last crazy Elton John step into
Christmas shout out to reliant K's
Christmas album that's maybe like five
of you in the comments all the Christian
rock fans okay let's move on return
actually to our trivia question that we
asked earlier what what okay so let's
redistribute the cards here I'll give
you I'll take mine who's tricked
[Music]
okay okay so just to remind you guys
what the question was
besides josh brolin I guess Chris Evans
what other actors have crossed over
between comics superhero cinematic
universes name as many as you can okay
so let's start down a line with Sam in
Reynolds JK Simmons yes
JK Simmons you played J jonah Jameson
and Commissioner Gordon we have Seth
Green he played Howard the Duck and then
the guy from Buffy the Vampire Slayer
set a comic universe yeah we'll count it
well count it yeah yeah Seth Green
and then finally beneath Chioda thought
he placed the collector and then he also
plays the guy in Sin City that's a
talking head works okay so I have a mods
we have Chris Evans the Human Torch and
then Michael Keaton stolen probably
after mine yeah and if you really wanna
get technical he's Birdman yeah yeah and
then but you're welcome for keeping the
show well all of you were thinking and
not speaking for 30 you have lutely dead
save the soda what we put in stuff right
charlie
and then mod who do you have my Ryan
Reynolds Jennifer Connelly okay so yeah
Michael Jennifer Connelly was in Hulk
but she was also the voice of the unit
of Peter Parker suit in spider-man home
[Music]
okay so he is in the upcoming a man in
the wasp and he plays Perry White and
not yet so does that count and no judge
does it count
yeah yeah Ben Affleck yeah obvious one
yeah daredevil where do ya Eric that's
an eric is yeah oh I put myself in my
own and these movies I got backwards
question mark a.m. he said Michael
Keaton copy I was looking at my own
paper yes black Ryan Reynolds Jennifer
Connelly no you know I know you cheated
POW because of how he responded with you
Jennifer Connelly was in the second one
you had oh yeah no I didn't say oh yeah
I said because I
yeah for sure
just to give you guys sent to some other
interesting ones Tommy Tommy Lee Jones
who was of course to face and he's in
Captain America the First Avenger Tom
Hardy and in black technically yeah
that's right that's right
Halle Berry played storm and Catwoman
yeah Doctor Strange yeah there's a ton
of these attorneys jeopardy Morgan was
in Batman vs Superman Anna's in Watchmen
as well as Patrick Willis was a watchman
in the upcoming Aquaman Bunch
so judges who won I'm gonna do our
good-byes in a bit but mod we're gonna
quickly run through the remaining Marvel
phase three schedule as a loser the
trivia question will have to read these
and the end of each movie title and
release it you have to come up with an O
so clever review headline that will be
written about that movie when it comes
out of names when there's pressure
okay first up Black Panther will
premiere on February the 18th 2018
around infinity will premiere on May the
4th which is not supposed to be a Marvel
day the how is mayor Ford not going to
be a Star Wars anything yeah
may the fourth not be with you Marvel's
burn thank you and the wasp will
premiere on July sting six it's like a
bee give it one sting and now I die
Marvel will premiere on my speedo 2019
which means by then I should be about 24
Wow and Avengers 4 will premiere on May
the 3rd which will be the 4th in the
southern hemisphere
probably not again they stuffed it up I
need to have a chat with Marvel about
their release dates and like missing out
on good pants just like I've been
missing out on all the good puns during
that because I've been so angry we know
who will cheer us up I got someone who
because this is the end of the year it's
time for the New Year's baby - you'll
get your guns right soon Oh waiter
my I thought your jokes were funny and
Tommy - good comment down below and
tweet us at new Rach season hashtag I
need to know and like this video share
it around discarded new rocks there
thank you to our panel here guys see you
next weekend perhaps in the new year hmm
bye bye
that's your final thought that's your
final thing on this year that that's the
cap on it